décision historique une première
condamnation d'un fabricant d'opioïdes
aux états unis à qui on reconnaît une
responsabilité dans la crise de santé
publique
johnson & johnson est condamné à payer
572 millions de dollars à l'état de
l'oklahoma
le fabricant annonce déjà qu'il ira en
appel que fera l'état on verra bien
aussi parce que l'état voulait 17
milliards de dollars décision fort
suivent au canada où deux provinces ont
tenté déjà des recours il ya aussi un
recours collectif en préparation au
québec ont invité celui-là faire de très
près maître patrick martin maintenant
bonsoir vous êtes avocat sans
responsabilité médicale de la fim
maintenant martin avocat bonsoir alors
va coûter si vous voulez bien le juge
tas de batman et le procureur général de
cet état de campagne
[Musique]
les chiffres sont absolument hallucinant
quand on pense au nombre de morts au
fait que l'on tente de mettre de l'avant
depuis des années sur les effets de des
opioïdes en quoi cette décision est
importante et où décevante en termes de
montant pour vous d'abord c'est une
décision importante parce c'est la
première de plus de 2000 poursuites qui
ont été déposées
aux etats unis 40 donc 48 par des états
plusieurs par des municipalités pour
tenter de récupérer les coûts les très
importants coûts publics en termes de
santé reliés à la crise et les
confitures également donc c'est un
premier cas qui si on veut rencontrer le
test des tribunaux puis effectivement
c'est une victoire en fait le pauvre le
gouverneur de l'oklahoma qui cherchait à
obtenir des fonds pour pouvoir mettre un
terme à cette crise pour payer les
interventions en santé et en sécurité
cela 10 17 milliards et 572 millions il
ya tout un écart grande déception de ce
côté là selon vous oui mais
effectivement nantis que le finalement
le loup clairement présenté un plan sur
20 ans le juge finalement de revenus la
preuve que sur un an
donc le vraiment donner une fraction de
ce qui était de ceux qui était demandé
c'est certain que le côté gouvernement
de l'oklahoma
il peut avoir une certaine déception par
ailleurs en bout de ligne ça reste une
importante victoire quand on pense trop
tôt la mer parce que si vous aussi avec
les deux autres compagnies qui avaient
réglé en cours peu avant le litige
l'une pour 280 millions l'autre pour 75
millions ont-ils un montant en fait qui
danse et qui est dans cet ordre là puis
surtout ça vient créer un précédent qui
va certainement changer le rapport de
force hier pour les prochaines aussi
pouvait pas en même temps qu'est ce
qu'on devait démontrer que les
pharmaceutiques savait qu'ils avaient
des conséquences vraiment pour la santé
publique pour la dépendance notamment
pour les surdoses oui en fait le code
l'oklahoma est particulier parce que ils
se sont appuyés sur la notion de
nuisance publique qui en oklahoma est
une notion extrêmement larges horizons
si finalement que la conduite des
compagnies à maastricht constituait une
nuisance publique qui avait occasionné
en fait des inconvénients et des
dommages à l'ensemble de la population
de l'eau clame à différents experts au
niveau super que ici au québec un
recours comme ce serait davantage selon
me fonder sur l'inaction peut-être plus
traditionnels que sont la faute le
dommage est le lien causal entre la
faute et le dommage donc de prouver
justement que d'une part les compagnies
savait ou aurait dû savoir que les
que les a priori david avait ses effets
et para para très bon tout ce qui est
justement de publicité mensongère et
tout est de rattacher sert donc de façon
probable aux dommages qui ont été si
vous avez évoqué la publicité mensongère
mes collègues enquêtes ont déjà fait de
vous retrouver sur dans nos archives un
doux c'est formidable
sur ce mensonge la publicité mensongère
et tous ce que savaient les compagnies
ici est ce qu on sait qu elle savait ce
qu'on a la capacité de faire la preuve
que ces corps que c'est pharmaceutique
la savait les conséquences nocives de
terre
oui absolument puis en fait si vous
disiez le jugement c'est vraiment en
fait il se dit prêt si comme une liste
d'épicerie de l'ensemble des manoeuvres
si on veut mensongères ou de mauvaise
foi qui aurait été fait par ces
compagnies là à la fois pour d'une part
encourager les médecins assurent
prescrite dans des quartiers où ce
n'était peut-être pas nécessairement
indiquiez donc des codes de douleurs
chroniques
d'autre part pour minimiser les effets
actifs en trafiquant nos différentes
passions les données donc en fait le
jugement est extrêmement intéressant ce
qui leur prend de façon succincte un
très long historique où on peut voir ce
genre de propos est parce qu idy
d'enfants dans son jugement que la
fameuse suite que johnson & johnson
nourri la crise au cac
un mythe dans le fond d'huile sur le feu
littéralement
ici donc deux poursuites si l'ontario et
la colombie-britannique au mans et voit
ce que ça donne et puis quelles sont les
chances de réussite en fait la colombie
britannique a lancé son recours
l'automne dernier l'ontario a nancy le
quelques mois qu'ils ont l'intention
d'emboîter on en est vraiment à un stade
très préliminaire aussi que ces recours
peuvent prendre très longtemps
bon québec les parieurs pour faire un
parallèle justement avec le tableau le
mans alors si son recours en 2012 pour
tenter de récupérer les coûts de santé
reliés à l'utilisation ce cow-boy encore
une fois l'oncle ça fait six ans et le
dossier est encore petit nous avons ici
un recours possible au québec est déjà
sur l'examen je suis pas sûr que l'on
fait donc ajustable le québec a déjà
adopté une loi spéciale pour aménager un
peu les sorties sans faire d'autres
oeuvres bon maintenant à savoir est-ce
que ce soit fait pour les accuser de ça
reste à voir si quand même un travail
qui est importante ou plusieurs
considérations qui rentrent en ligne de
compte rien vie aux médecins qui sera
tenté d'en prescrire trop j'adore ce que
je te dis en un qui été condamné à 157
en prison merci m ménard je le suis